إن الوضع الإنساني في غزة
مفجع للغاية، والأمر لا يتعلق
بالأرقام فحسب، بل يتعلق أيضًا
بعقود من المجتمع يتم
رفعها إلى أنقاض الأيتام الذين
تركوا وراءهم، ويجب أن أخبرك أنه
بصفتي
برلمانيًا بريطانيًا، لم أفعل ذلك.  تلقيت
الكثير من رسائل البريد الإلكتروني حول أي موضوع واحد
قبل أن تستحوذ على قلوب
الجمهور البريطاني،
يعتقد حزبي، الديمقراطيون الليبراليون، أن الآن هو
الوقت المناسب
لوقف إطلاق النار الثنائي الفوري وليس الحقائق أو فترات التوقف
التي نشهدها لأن
المشكلة في التوقف المؤقت هي أنه يقبل
أن هذا المستوى من الدمار
مقبول ولكن مع ذلك نريد أيضًا
التأكد من أننا في هذا البرلمان
نناقش ما سيحدث بعد ذلك، فإن وقف إطلاق النار
ليس كافيًا، ولا يكفي أن
نوقف هذا الذي نحتاج إليه.  لكي نصل إلى النقطة
التي يكون لدينا فيها دولة فلسطينية قابلة للحياة،
فإن حل الدولتين مع
عيش الشعبين دون خوف هو ما
نريد أن نهدف إليه، ومن أجل القيام بذلك،
علينا أن نكون واقعيين،
ولن يقبل المجتمع الدولي أن تكون حماس
جزء من هذا الحل ولكن لن
يكون نتنياهو على حق، ويتعين علينا أن
نبدأ بالفعل في التفكير
كمجتمع دولي في كيفية ضمان
أن حل الدولتين، ذلك
السلام الذي كنا نتوق إليه جميعًا
لأجيال عديدة، أصبح الآن أخيرًا
على أرض الواقع.  كما
يطلب مني الآن ناخبي البريطانيون، وكان
حزبي يشعر بالقلق إزاء هذه
الخطوة من جانب الحكومة البريطانية
لإرسال طائرات بدون طيار لأنها شعرت
بأنها أحادية الجانب للغاية، وشعرت أنهم كانوا يساعدون
الإسرائيليين فقط وكان بإمكانهم فعل ذلك في
نفس الوقت.  كان من الواضح جدًا أنهم
سيتأكدون أيضًا من أن
أي دليل يجمعونه سيتم
إرساله أيضًا إلى أولئك الذين يبحثون عن
أدلة على جرائم الحرب على سبيل المثال
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
ولم يفعلوا ذلك، لذلك في البرلمان نحن  لقد
أعربنا عن هذا القلق، وقد قلنا
مراراً وتكراراً أن أي دليل
يتم جمعه ينبغي السماح
بإرساله إلى أولئك الذين يهدفون إلى
محاسبة ما يحدث على
الأرض في غزة، ونحن نعتقد أن هذه
خطوة مهمة  تم
إطلاق سراح الرهائن وهؤلاء أناس أبرياء أيضًا
وهؤلاء أشخاص ناضلوا من أجل
السلام، وكثير منهم لذلك أنا
قلق جدًا بشأن الحكومة البريطانية أه
بأي شكل من الأشكال أن ينظر إليهم على أنهم متواطئون أه لقد
حذرناهم من أن هذا هو ما
يبدو عليه الأمر  وقد أكدوا لنا أيضًا أنهم
سيساعدون عسكريًا في
إدخال المساعدات، وأعتقد أن هذا أمر
مرحب به، لكنني أعتقد أن
الحكومة البريطانية لم تركز
بشكل صحيح على كونها عادلة لكل من
الفلسطينيين والإسرائيليين.  من
المؤكد أن هناك تصورًا في بريطانيا بأن
هذه الحكومة انحازت إلى جانب
الحكومة الإسرائيلية وأعتقد أن هذا
يتطلب تحدي الرسالة التي أحملها إلى
الناس في فلسطين وفي جميع أنحاء
العالم العربي وهي أن الجمهور البريطاني
ينظر إلى ما يحدث
دمار لا يوصف الرعب وهم
متأثرون بشدة ونحن نرى هذا في
الاحتجاجات ونرى هذا في الوقفات الاحتجاجية
أيًا كان الأشخاص الأبرياء
المتأثرين بهذا، فنحن نعلم أن هذا
لا يمكن أن يستمر وما
يقوله البرلمانيون في البرلمان البريطاني لـ  بعضنا البعض هو أننا
لا نستطيع أن نقف مكتوفي الأيدي ونترك هذا
يحدث لفترة طويلة جدًا، لقد ترك السلام
بين الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
على كومة صعبة للغاية
ولم يعد
مستقبلًا يمكننا قبوله، نريد أن
يتغير هذا، نحن مطالبون
بتغييره  لقد تم ذلك من قبل ناخبينا
وآمل حقًا أن يتقدم البرلمان البريطاني
والحكومات البريطانية المستقبلية
إلى اللوحة ويجعل ذلك
حقيقة واقعة